thank you
[Music]
so this is something I never thought
about and it made me pretty sad because
I didn't realize how a non-asian would
feel
we'll take this yeah you guys won't you
guys will understand this because you've
been around this culture but there was a
tick tock that went viral of this girl
who was asked to leave a Korean barbecue
restaurant because she was dining by
herself
what that's [ __ ] up you know how all
you can eat caves I know you can't go in
there to eat alone you didn't you can't
yes
I almost went the other day and I
stopped myself because I remember what I
didn't know that if it's all you can eat
you have to have minimum two people oh
well apparently all ages
what that's always the fallacy in here
is it because like the fair is not
covering the cost of I guess the table
because they could that's they're losing
like a potential six cut exactly yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and most like all you can eat places
have it written down like in the front
somewhere it's very like visible that
you can't I did not I really didn't know
that yeah but they they would kick her
out even if they're not busy yeah you're
still making money yeah they would they
would still because it's just policy and
they shame you too they should make fun
of you shame get a friend yeah bring
some people so it's really sad because
so she filmed she actually like filmed
herself being like asked to leave but
the lady was like kind of trying to be
nice she's like hey next time you know
come next time with bring a friend
you're never going and then this girl
said she she like sat in the car and
cried
what that's very sad because she doesn't
know like she doesn't know the whole
thing about like but there's so many
restaurants around in general you would
if you wanted Korean barbecue let me
just go on Instagram
was she like in mid-meal or no she they
hadn't served her yet they just like
they she showed her because she signed
up on the wait list and wrote one and
then I guess like she was being shown to
the table and then was like oh are you
by yourself she was like yeah and then
they were like oh sorry like you don't
do that oh she wasn't sad didn't have
like a [ __ ] ice water in front of her
I don't know how far is she she started
filming it when she was already like
Nick has something to say no I don't
there's a trash foreign
get some friends dude who goes to eat
Korean barbecue by themselves I almost
did the other day they're the number one
argument all right in this situation
just go to a non all you can eat Korean
barbecue there's a lot of those too but
it doesn't stop the embarrassment that
she went through because she didn't you
know when you just don't know you don't
know the rules you're just like it just
feels like [ __ ] but he has to leave and
like they were just really rubbing in
that you're alone it's pretty [ __ ]
hard doesn't it make it more
embarrassing when you like put it on
social media and it goes viral though I
don't think she understood she didn't
understand that this was a thing that
like a lot of places you're just pissed
at Koreans but was she one of those like
this she goes in the car
no
like that one of those was he said she
filmed the moment that she's getting
like then then they go
they upload about both of those things
the Preamble and the post animal [ __ ]
a lot of likes that was really good I
haven't she actually filmed it pretty
Tastefully she didn't film the crime
part she was just talking about it but
she all she filmed was her being like
the lady going like oh hey like yeah we
don't do that so
I think she did a pretty okay job
filming it she wasn't like super
dramatic she was she was nice too like
she was like oh okay sorry like she
clearly was like uh new to that concept
it is kind of sad to get like escorted
out of a restaurant and it's not like
you [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] this it's just like you just came
by yourself yeah yeah the waiters
walking out to it and then everyone's
walking by he's like
oh no friends no friends yeah
you got another one
no friends that's okay hey can you get
the door for the no friends girl this is
how they fix it you know how when you go
to like Disneyland you don't want to
wait in the long line okay they have a
separate line or single right fast pass
you get single Riders so you get all the
[ __ ] losers that don't have friends
and then you make them sit together at
one table so all the loners get to come
in yeah yeah yeah hey that is kind of
cool and I'll be in the single writer's
line because I almost went last week and
I thought about I was like I was gonna
go by myself like a loser a lot of
things about like Korean barbecue like a
lot of the restaurants that do that all
you can eat style for them to be
efficient the way especially in the
culture of that food too they have like
100 side dishes
already gotta rush out [ __ ] display
every single thing wipe it up you know
what I mean and they got this giant fan
and smoke blowing everywhere and pulling
out all his meat so it's like to even
like have a single person sit down and
like have all of that immediate service
is like so anti you know the efficiency
of what they do so that's why they need
to have them yeah because all those
entrees could be like 20 bucks already
yeah that's why you need two three four
five whatever to cover the cost of just
those exactly just for Korean barbecue
Devil's Advocate okay here we go
let's say I'm like a famous person and I
don't wanna you know have to deal with
anything all right can I just sit down
and like be like hey I'll pay like for
the whole table whole table
yeah I think you can do that because
what it says is not it's not always
minimum people two it says minimum
orders too minimum I'm Asian give me
money yeah so if you paid for the space
across you I think they would be okay
with that because they're still making
the money that they would think they're
losing and you can't take food home you
have to pay for the additional food if
you do take it home yeah I think if you
eat by yourself you get to take a little
food off you better get to take a little
food off if you're paying for two seats
you get to take a look but you have to
bring your own ZIP locks okay fair no
to-go boxes or anything because they
don't have that they don't store [ __ ]
together but if you bring Ziplocs aren't
they a little bit so I saw on you
already
foreign
don't worry about my own Ziplocs
you don't need the Ziplocs to walk into
a Korean barbecue and looks less
why yeah
[Laughter]
what are you trying to say
what's interesting too is um I think a
lot of people because we've grown up
around lots of different Asian
restaurants and uh maybe there should be
some way to communicate to everyone else
most Asian restaurants are not really
very sensitive to what you want or need
they're pretty like some of them are
pretty logical cut and dry and kind of
don't give a [ __ ] almost too logical
yeah a little bit so I could see why
like someone would think oh that's so
cold that's so rude it's like you know
they're trying to make money and
maximize profits you know which one's
illogical then they're not trying to
make money because they're [ __ ] dumb
as [ __ ] the [ __ ] Japanese ones
let's go to closing hours well there's
that but the Japanese people like
culturally they're so like like they
abide by the rules so much Etc except
for Joe yeah but like you know
Shinsengumi the the
um that Tokyo the ramen okay yeah yeah
so I go there
it's busy there's like a line out the
door right and we're trying to [ __ ]
eat and then there's a table for like
four and then I'm like oh there's a can
we just sit there real quick like we're
just looking really gonna eat and just
and Just Bounce and she's like oh no
it's a poor people
well me and my friend will sit there and
I could even sit with two other
strangers you'll make your line shorter
poor people groups that come together
and then so we end up waiting for like
two hours the whole just because that
table is meant for a table of four so
for them it's like this is what this is
for and that's it and they can't be
flexible bend the rules or anything like
that oh yeah that's another [ __ ] open
to that Chinese bamboo very strong
Chinese a hooligan want to sit at the
poor table oh my God damn school again
yeah he means four no I think he means
poor yeah clearly clearly it's poor and
the Japanese people are always like that
yeah if that's the rules and they're not
the ones that can make the call I could
cheat yeah when I go to uh the other
place down here that I like the sushi
spot like all the entrees come with the
Miso soup right always and then you go
oh um want the clam miso soup can I swap
it out just pay the up charge oh no no
this this miso soup come with the entree
and I'm like well what if I want to
climb me so stupid you have to order
separate so because of that I always get
two miso soup they just can't just [ __ ]
in you know like
Fram there's this little none of that uh
Devil's really cool and flexible oh yeah
yeah we got another guy going to get the
grade here
um I would assume it's their POS system
that they can't separate a four percent
[ __ ] Abacus in the back they gotta
fix that yeah they gotta fix two
different tables or like in ordering you
can't like just like mix and match
because they only have that order as
like that one thing that [ __ ] that old
lady probably don't know how to like
change [ __ ] so I would assume the
Japanese POS system it's probably the
best you need to get one by Intel yeah
because it'll be like table three but
you can't split table three and how
because she doesn't know how to give two
different receipts or something like
that but you know what it's a split
Focus that's their fault bar I'm just
playing Devil's Advocate don't get mad
at him because don't get mad at me
because when you go to [ __ ] Chinese
restaurant Anything is Possible
you could look at the menu and a [ __ ]
Hong Kong Cafe already has like 300
things literally from Pizza to french
fries to [ __ ] is anything sandwiches
right you could go like that and go I
don't want any of this I want lo mein
with [ __ ] cheese on it and they'd be
like I don't know how to do that but we
can do it for you
go figure it out
restaurants you're like hey uh I'm a
vegetarian so like no meat right okay
here's cabbage but it's all cooked in
pork oil yeah see they figured it out
that's true they are just like a get it
done group but you know you may not get
what you wanted but it happened they're
not gonna say no they want your money at
all costs cash only leads back to the
profiteering aspect it closes like you
like they're like their kitchen closes
at like 11 30 or something right and if
you show up at 11 29 a [ __ ] Chinese
restaurant but oh okay
yeah they're like oh no Kitchen close
everyone's tired
that's the PSA of the day
um a lot of Asian all you can eat places
they will require you to have a friend
other than Heidi Lau which if you go
there with one person they put a giant
teddy bear across from you that's more
insulting actually that's weird
that hurts my feelings yeah I don't want
the teddy bear tonight yeah just maybe I
don't want to be accompanied by this
plus they have cold eyes yeah they have
cold out they're just staring at you the
whole time
[Music]
foreign
foreign